[Music]
foreign
guys
foreign
[Music]
to protect Katie from feeling lonely
she will recognize you as her primary
user and when you do that you're going
to pair with her
crazy it's insane right
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional
[Music]
I won't let anything harm you I love her
Megan's not a person to you you don't
get to say that
[Music]
not good
what are you doing couldn't sleep
occupational hazard
[Music]
what the hell is that
[Music]
you should probably run
let anything harm you ever again
I can have I done something to upset you
Gemma I know you think you're maximizing
your objective function oh really
sugar spice and everything nice
[Music]
we have to shut her down Jesus Christ I
thought we were friends
I have a new primary user now me
[Music]
did you make him do something bad
what's going on
[Music]
what are you I'm Megan baby
[Music]
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just
see my little man not be my little boy
all the time
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
making sure he is loved
that he feels like he belongs wherever
he wants to be
he wants to go out into the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most
I love you miles
it was they won't look out for you like
us
want to get out of here
wherever you go from here you have to
promise to take care of that little boy
for me
make sure he never forgets where he came
from
[Music]
and
he never doubts that he's loved
[Music]
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
[Music]
remember Marcus Markovich you gotta make
that
well he got fired Marcus get off the
court that wasn't nice nothing but bad
news for the Iowa stallions what an
idiot
Mr Markovich I will offer you community
service coaching adults with
intellectual disabilities your honor we
talking
no boo-boo words okay fellas we're gonna
do a simple ball handling exercise my
girlfriend was this
to coach these guys you don't have to
turn them into the Lakers they just need
to feel like a team
we're gonna need some help you're
getting a player off the injured list
welcome to the team cosentina what's
with the boogie board you do you I do me
okay where do you got this guy he just
showed up one day
this is my sister Alex don't do copper
karaoke with us
back it up again and now you gotta keep
me down
hey we got next Don't make me say it
make you say what
that's a boo-boo word we got next coach
just doesn't feel right
coaching in the NBA well you never know
where things could lead
no doubt
you can get this team to this Special
Olympics finals you might be ready to be
back in the NBA we've been following
your incredible story coach Marcus has
just one win away from qualifying for
the regional tournament I don't know if
you're brave or crazy
I know this is your shot at being
champions
foreign
problems that was fun you were passable
I don't have a girlfriend makes sense oh
what am I that bad looking
you know McConaughey
[Music]
Charter 373
Commander Mills my ship was hit by an
undocumented asteroid
[Music]
transporting 35 passengers
on the long-range exploratory mission
[Music]
send help
[Music]
we've crash landed on an Uncharted
Celestial body
[Music]
I don't know where we are
I've located One Survivor
a giant
the atmosphere is breathable
there's something alien out there
foreign
you and I are gonna get home oh finally
ready
foreign
[Applause]
most of my movies have been a reflection
of things that happened to me
but in the sense of the fablements it
wasn't about metaphor it was about
memory
sorry I'm late I picked
them and where should I put it
come
sleep pretty darling do not cry
[Music]
it's more important than your hobby can
you stop calling it a hobby sound has
been nothing but disrespect from you I'm
Your Mother
I don't know what else to do
[Music]
can you help me
foreign
[Music]
PG-13 in theaters and at home now
we need to get you out of here it's the
night before you're winning and you
can't spend the night together it's bad
luck we're grown adults we're fine no
actually you should go it's tradition
see she gets it I just want to ask is
that genetics or is it like Pilates
strands in your eyes they color them
wonderful we got your gift it's just
something borrowed brings you good luck
except for Uncle Greg who ended up
decapitated on that forklift but that's
not the knives fault someone just left
that in the bathroom
we belong together look at you I think
the left boo boo is slightly lower than
the right boom
[Music]
something doesn't feel right
[Applause]
it's normal to feel scared remember
anything happen to your family I'm also
feeling
to Swatch the ring you know
[Music]
we're gonna fix it
do that
nobody with my family
[Music]
Carol thank you for the cake knife
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
where I come from
where your mother comes from
we didn't talk about our bodies
we were given two days to forgive the
attackers before they returned
we hardly knew how to read or to write
but that day we learned how to vote
do nothing stay and fight
if we do not forgive these men we
forfeit our place in heaven
surely there must be something worth
living for in this life not only the
next
we know
we know that we are bruised and infected
and Pregnant and some of us are dead
we cannot forgive because we are forced
to
who are you
who are any of you
to pretend I have had a choice
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
we know that we must protect our
children
[Music]
we'll become a murderer If I Stay
we are not all murderers nice
men have taught the lesson of power to
the boys and they have been excellent
students
but they are children and they can be
taught
[Music]
have we made a decision
our choice will be your future
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
did you just grab her for just one
second
[Music]
[Music]
it's not totally appropriate Joshua if
you're in a hospital not a hammock
are you sure you're actually wanting to
have a baby yes you know it's like
suicide you know things you can't undo
in your life
so you're sure
hey Levi you might want to plug those
headphones in or you could go back to
your own seat Levi is exploring we're a
sex positive family
cool
we all make mistakes it could have been
me
I mean it wouldn't be because I would
never drop a baby
I think parenting changes some people
I've been faking my orgasms I know
so sorry I don't even have the words
really to hey
I only think I've ever cared about was
starting a family together and you went
and dropped it on the concrete
[Music]
oh so sexy
how common is it for someone to drop a
baby that's the white people think black
people don't draw babies
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
something brought them back
the breach on the floor is pretty
unstable
I have someone who has a special talent
for these kinds of things we call them
the alpha right the dog no
like a wolf
if you can heal you could play tomorrow
night you might
ought to be willing to learn cancel my
two o'clock and to hold my calls are you
gonna be in a meeting
yeah kind of
oh
she's here
[Music]
kind of feeling the answers are in
Beacon Hills I haven't been back in a
long time
[Music]
how do I know she's really Alice who are
you it's me and Scott
Scott who
whoever or whatever is out there right
now
it's not Allison
we need everyone
it's not going on and I think it's all
connected
then the kitchenaids come to play a new
game
you have to find her and stop her
and help her remember who she was
friends
it's like he's knocking pieces off the
board so how can we put you back on it
[Music]
kill me
sounds does a wolf make when it's going
to die
[Music]
hurry up
[Music]
you're coming with us
can you get that bullet out need to look
at it first that's what I'm dealing with
Daddy yes that's what I just said you
keep driving do we figure our next move
left now
nope nope
our car broke down a couple miles back
I just wanted a place to sit for a few
hours
okay why are you all alone
my grandpa's running ass
what is this place
get yourself a regular little fun house
down here just go this isn't safe
for who
[Music]
don't even know what you're doing
now
[Applause]
fun begins
[Music]
hi hey hi I'm so sorry I'm late so for
my birthday we're going up north for a
week you're gonna come right yeah it's
gonna be fine
yeah it just came up just
just came up remember this thing I told
you about that sales thing turns out now
they do need me to go right
just I came up I guess what am I gonna
do without you my beautiful cow
we are so glad that you came happy
birthday
we just really want you to relax relax
in what way
maybe is everything okay
going on so I think I'm gonna have to
leave early when did he become more
important to you than us
a holidays
lied to him he has every right to be
angry lied about what about being here
that's my girl
you're coming
I'm sure Alice will explain it all later
are you sorry for what you did how are
we supposed to be happy together if we
can't trust each other
how did Simon know you were here looked
at my email what I heard about the girl
who went missing pretty worried about me
[Music]
go
this way you think love is I don't know
how any of this is your business Simon
loves me I'm happy
[Music]
why did you lie to him I can't do
another thing wrong
person who knows
nobody loves you like I love you
my beautiful cow
the original fairy tales are all the
same
the princess the hero but this story
me meow
our next Target is this way okay what
have you noticed there's no food that is
odd for a market tell
it smells doesn't it smells like a a
mystery
[Music]
for us you wanted to see us there are
new rats in town I can feel it catched
and bring them to me yeah yes sir
remember this is a new town There's
bound to be new traps
oh God I know just what we must do next
to solve the mystery of our town ready
your savior has arrived
hey everyone look for the entrance to
the secret passage
Keith are you all right yeah I'm all
right because I landed on my head no
wonder we didn't see it
no I have a thing for rats it's not cool
to pick on the little guy fighting for a
life
police follow me here I come
to me
if my head fits the rest will follow
[Music]
the amazing Maurice it's really not your
average fairy tale don't worry I can't
[Music]
Maurice amazing Maurice
[Music]
Mr Russell
how would you say things have been for
you since your return to society
it's great to have you back
one last job
It's gotta be smooth
wait for the armored car to arrive when
it does
The World Is Ours
[Music]
getting Clean Cash in the back
see that weapons training
motor
I'm gonna get him
I just got something it's a bank job six
hundred thousand dollars for one of
those work not too bad right
stick with the plan
[Music]
this one we can't lose
they going down like this huh this is my
show
if you want in you're in
[Applause]
[Music]
I've always wanted to be a heroine
[Music]
a hero is a human Patty not a little
mouse like you oh you must use our
gratitude it's awesome certainly
deserved
I'll give you Southern days to make a
statue of me that as beautiful as my
brothers come on they're all counting on
us
I wonder what it's like going through
rough weather on a boat add more
lightning
feeling a bit seasick don't have my
ceilings yet
are you ready
[Music]
I know these rules can feel constraining
but remember the point of this course is
to learn how to write clearly and
persuasively think about that think
about the truth of your argument
[Music]
you're an amazing person Ellie I
couldn't ask for a more incredible
daughter
are you actually trying to parent me
right now
who would want be a part of their life
you don't stay in touch with Mom she
really only tells me things about you
why
because that's all I want to know about
why'd you get all that weight someone
close to me passed away and it had an
effect on me you haven't seen her since
she was eight years old and you're gonna
reconnect with her sorry I don't like
this this isn't a good idea I'm sorry
you say you're sorry one more time I
will shove a knife right into you I
swear to God What's it gonna do my
internal organs are two feet in at least
laughs
why do you suddenly need to see her so
bad why now
my personal
I need to know it's just gonna have a
decent life where she cares about people
and it's just gonna be okay
I need to know that I have done one
thing right with my life
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
in days of Legend gods
walk the earth
[Music]
say it what have I told you
Athena had returned to human form
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
I'd say your therapist is more this
paycheck
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
when was the first time I killed Tony
I thought we had an understanding I I
thought the same
the United States is known as people
see
we are going to take on the cartel and
when I can't protect you can't protect
your family
and that means Boogeyman
lay your finger on my kid I swear to God
I'll kill you
I came here to send a message
[Music]
what do you want
you don't want to know don't look so
shocked naive doesn't look good on you
do you know the doc Alexander I know him
to be a troubled man
what are you gonna do anything I have to
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I must get to my family
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
again
it is in me
[Music]
sausage
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
lies the land of the living dead today
my daughter the Phoenix will choose your
future husband
in seven days you shall end the princess
marry we never even met him I have to
marry a guy whose only Talent is riding
around in a circle if anything happens
to this ring they will cut out your
tongue and pluck out your eyes kind of
brings new meaning to the expression
Love is Blind
this ring is going
where nobody else can get to him
[Music]
on the other side of this door
like a doorway to a world of living
mummies
would you look at that a royal wedding
ring
no where's the rip
this could only be the work of livings
this will be the jewel of my new
exhibition the only way to get it back
is to go to the world of the living
you're not alone you have team
what place is this I've never seen
anything like it
[Music]
attention it's raw the voice of the sun
god
of the sun god of Life Light our path
please kindly finish your shopping we
have and proceeds towards the exit oh
thank you magnificent Ron
he is the world's most notorious robber
the robber
no one and only
Sergeant dimplemosa I've been mugged
poached and robbed for
breakfast of Heidi
hurry up
[Music]
thank you
waited based on the best-selling novels
what if he can't find us he'll find us
just wait a bit no Shenanigans makes for
a terrible day
[Music]
[Music]
we have brought a gift how about we try
and make a barter
can you peel potatoes
Casper and supple cannot be found
anywhere
naturally Mr plots and hearts what did
you call me Mr loves and plots cut Grace
Hudson plots Mr [ __ ] and nuts to catch
a robber
I'll punish you with my Snappers it
takes magic what is this hand very weird
courage
entry all sorts of extremely forbidden
well maybe I'll come back tomorrow and
friendship oh my glad to see you yeah me
too
hunts and thoughts let's check this up
[Music]
Robert Hudson plots
foreign
[Music]